POTS is not cause of something. It's
it's really the reaction to something
else. So So POTS to me is really a
symptom
and it's a symptom of a breakdown in
that regulatory system you're talking
about. The one that kind of regulates
your blood pressure, regulates your
heart rate, controls things when you
stand up and sit down. So something's
gone wrong with the circuitry there. Um,
you might have, you know, had a
concussion and damaged that area or, you
know, maybe you had a toxic reaction to
a medication or a vaccine or something's
happened where that those circuits have
been damaged. And the treatments these
days, for the most part, they're really
just basically covering up the symptoms.
[Music]